Hollywood's new guard may be here
tonight but our next presenter
represents Hawley was old guard a real
veteran she started one of Hollywood's
biggest box-office hits of all time
she's been acting for 18 years and she's
only 22 the other four years I guess she
was directing she is the only member of
a royal family on the show tonight so
please welcome drew Barrymore
evening I am honored to say that for
four generations Barrymore's have been
embraced by one of our theaters most
subtle arts makeup today we who appear
on camera are indebted to those artists
who make us look better or worse as the
role demands so here are the nominees
for the best achievement in makeup this
year for men in black Rick Baker and
David Lee Roy Anderson skillfully
combined paint powder and plastics with
their imaginations and turned an
otherwise pleasant citizen into a most
unpleasant alien for mrs. Brown Lisa
Westcott Veronica Brebner and Beverly
Binda researched history books that
helped them create the authentic look of
a queen and her court in the last
century for Titanic Tina
Earnshaw greg cannom and Simon Thompson
met the challenge of designing deathlike
frozen faces for hundreds of formerly
festive passengers and the Oscar goes to
David Lee Roy Anderson and Rick Baker
four men in black
overlaps created makeup magic for the
oscar-winning Nutty Professor Rick Baker
has also aa twister Edward Harry and the
Henderson and in America
wolf in London
we'd like to thank the Academy Columbia
Amblin Steven Spielberg Barry Sonnenfeld
Walter Laurie Graham and Steve Mullen
for making the film Don Peterman for his
photography get well done a special
thanks to my crew I'm honored to work
with such talented artists you're only
as good as your crew and I guess this
means I have a damn good crew Vincent
D'Onofrio and Tony Shalhoub for their
patience and cooperation Vincent was
incredibly patient while David and I
practically tortured him and lastly I'd
like to thank my wife Sylvia and my
daughters Veronica and Rebecca for their
love and support and for teaching me the
meaning of joy I love you guys very much
thank you
you